des supporters déchaînés dans la
capitale libérienne les scènes de joie
lors d'un meeting de l'ex footballeur
vedette george weah
le président tente de mobiliser une
dernière fois avant le référendum
constitutionnel partisans distinguer
mesdames et messieurs je veux que vous
disiez oui au référendum parce que c'est
dans votre intérêt
deux millions et demi de libériens
appelés à se prononcer sur huit
amendements à la constitution de 1986
les électeurs doivent notamment dire
s'ils sont pour ou contre la réduction
de 6 à 5 ans de la durée du mandat
présidentiel
une révision constitutionnelle qui
propose aussi de réduire d'une année la
durée des mandats des députés et de deux
ans ceux des sénateurs un référendum qui
dérange dans les rangs de l'opposition
je vais voter trois oui les cinq autres
seront des noms vous savez en ce qui
concerne le référendum je n'ai pas
encore compris donc pour le référendum
je n'y ferais pas vraiment en fait
j'estime que le référendum n'est pas
important et je pense qu'il n'aurait pas
dû avoir lieu à ce moment là car il n'y
a pas eu beaucoup de publicité autour du
référendum
les contestataires craignent que george
weah tire profit du changement de
constitution une alliance composée des
quatre principaux partis d'opposition
estiment que peu des lecteurs
comprennent la portée des changements
proposés et appellent au boycott
il briguera un troisième mandat
simplement parce que ses six premières
années se serait déroulée sous une autre
constitution voté oui pour référendum
serait une erreur pour l'opposition le
président libérien pourrait un jour
vouloir imiter certains de ses pairs
ouest africain en allant au delà de la
limite de deux mandats présidentiels
autre question qui continue à diviser la
société du liberia la double
ciot nalité interdits depuis 1973
le projet de nouvelle constitution
prévoit que tout enfant né d'au moins un
parent libériens serait automatiquement
un citoyen naturelles du pays et qu'il
aurait le droit de détenir une autre
nationalité
une chose est sûre le référendum prend
la forme d'un test pour georges weah qui
voit sa popularité largement érodé
notamment auprès des jeunes qu'il avait
pourtant porté au pouvoir il ya près de
trois ans l'élection de l'homme de 54
ans ballon d'or france football 1995 a
soulevé un immense espoir au liberia
mais depuis que j'en jouais à est
président la situation économique s'est
encore aggravée dans ce pays d'afrique
de l'ouest notamment avec la crise du
courant d'un virus